this is the world's strongest magnet
capable of sucking objects in generating
electric current can you see that and
levitating non-magnetic objects it even
wreaks havoc on camera equipment wires
magnetic so if it's a CMOS sensor the
electrons just can't find their way well
they get redirected so yeah if you
notice bad video or audio know that it's
incredibly hard to shoot in these
magnetic fields
a portion of this video was sponsored by
Google
came to the National High magnetic field
laboratory in Tallahassee Florida where
since the year 2000 they have held the
Guinness World Record for the strongest
continuous magnetic field somebody who
left a chair where it wasn't supposed to
be it then got accelerated across the
cell completely pulled the guts out of
the chair now we all have those nice
super uncomfortable wooden chairs for
reference the magnetic field the Earth
is
.0005 Tesla a fridge magnet is around
.01 Tesla MRI machines can get up to
three Tesla but this electromagnet
creates a magnetic field of 45 Tesla so
nearly a million times Earth's magnetic
field
to achieve this field the magnet
consists of an outer superconducting
magnet and an inner resistive magnet
I'll explain why you need both types in
a moment the apparatus is two stories
tall but the maximum field or Field
Center only occurs in the center of a
narrow cylinder that runs through the
middle right now it's off is it there's
no matter can I put my finger in the
board
is that a bad idea no it's fine you can
totally do that
what is it
so that's where there's 45 Tesla further
down a meter away from meter down and so
that just drops down for it's clear all
the way all the way through to the
bottom oh wow the maximum field is
basically a centimeter tall here we have
very small samples think something like
a chip in a computer or a cell phone
that's what users will come in with so
that's plenty big for what we want to do
with Material Science or condensed
matter research since we can't see or
film in the center of the magnet we're
going to experiment with the magnetic
field that extends above and around the
magnet on this platform so the magnets
over there yes with the magnetic field
extends all the way out here yes and
past this is known as The Fringe field
and although it's much weaker than 45
Tesla it is still plenty dangerous for
our super inducting magnet
it depends on the size of that pore so
the bigger the bore the larger The
Fringe field because the magnetic flux
does not penetrate the windings and you
have to form a complete Loop so those
Loops just move further and further and
further out to make that feel
so this is the 100 Gauss line for The
Fringe field so what happens to objects
around 100 Gauss line things with shapes
will start orienting themselves to the
field so if you have it sitting on a
tabletop
say over here
it will start pivoting on its own and if
you get it too much closer it will just
go and by the time you notice it's
moving it's already too late meaning if
no ferromagnetic objects within the
hundred Gauss line if you have anything
ferromagnetic on you any implants that
are metallic
pacemaker anybody anybody anybody okay
ramping up this magnet to full power
takes around an hour and a half that's
because they have to put 47 000 amps of
current into the outer superconducting
electromagnet forty seven thousand
seven thousand amps 500 volts
it's so insane
all right so let's take it all the way
up to full field
one thing that happens in a strong
magnetic field obviously is that
magnetic materials aren't attracted to
it we cut open a Nerf football and put
in a couple steel washers being careful
to tape it up so the washers can't get
out we also covered the opening to the
magnet so the ball won't get sucked down
into it I got an unmodified Nerf
football
sure enough it's easy to tell which ball
contains the washers
I tried to throw the football and hit
the side of the magnet
after a few misses
it bounced around and stuck
it should have looked more like this
another thing to do if you have a strong
magnet is get ferrofluid ferrofluid
contains nanoscale pieces of magnetite
that's an iron containing mineral and
they're suspended in solution coated in
surfactant so they don't all Clump
together but in an external magnetic
field they all line up like iron filings
around a bar magnet this ferrofluid
started to develop parallel ridges even
meters away from the magnet and as we
got closer spikes formed on the surface
aligning the magnetite particles with
the field
closer still and the ferrofluid climbed
up the side of the vessel so it's not
much but it's just kind of a little bit
of a tug yeah and then try and tilt it
away and then you'll feel the difference
oh yeah it it definitely preferentially
wants to come this way magnetite is
actually the mineral that led people to
discover the phenomenon of magnetism in
the first place at least three thousand
years ago naturally magnetized pieces of
magnetite were found in a part of Greece
called magnesia that's actually where
the word magnet comes from in Greek they
were called stones from magnesia but
they were also referred to as lodestones
and it was discovered that lodestones
could attract each other or pieces of
iron and by the 11th century in China it
was realized that magnets could be used
to make a compass needle that would
always point in the same direction the
side that pointed to the north of the
Earth was referred to as a North seeking
pole and the other side the South
seeking pole though these days we often
just say North Pole and South Pole of
the magnet
but why why are only some materials
magnetic
electrons are essentially tiny magnets
but in most atoms they are paired up one
pointing one way and the other point in
the opposite way so their fields cancel
out in elements with half full outer
shells of electrons well then they can't
pair up so atoms have magnetic fields
but if neighboring atoms aren't aligned
well then the magnetic fields of all the
atoms cancel out and the bulk material
is non-magnetic but even if you get all
these atoms aligning in one part of the
material known as a domain they may be
aligned opposite atoms in other domains
and cancel out so you need all the
domains to be aligned normally when you
see these they're really strong magnets
but not here not yet and this can be
done by applying a strong external
magnetic field so right now these are
not magnetic they do not stick to each
other but he is loading them in there
into the hammerholtz coil
and then you get a permanent magnet
materials that meet these criteria are
called ferromagnetic after iron the most
common magnetic element but nickel and
Cobalt are also ferromagnetic in the
powerful magnetic field around the
world's strongest magnet what is even
more surprising to see is the behavior
of non-ferromagnetic materials here we
have four sheets of different materials
two different types of plastic copper
and aluminum when they are stationary in
the field there's no difference between
them but when they move
materials that conduct electricity fall
a lot slower
I'll get into that but first this
portion of the video was sponsored by
Google and they were interested in this
video because it's all about magnets
which are core to our future electric
vehicles for example use electric motors
which need magnets to work and U.S
search interest for electric vehicle
reached an all-time high in the last 12
months that is according to Google
Trends a tool that allows you to see
what people are searching for the thing
that connects these trending searches
and many others is that people are
trying to find ways of doing things that
are less destructive to the planet and
Google is like we live on this planet
too we also want to do that in fact
Google has matched 100 of their
electricity use with renewable energy
since 2017. they also run project
sunroof which helps people decide if
solar is right for their home by
providing Google Maps data to create a
3D model of your roof and estimate
Energy savings from rooftop solar
personally I'm just happy to learn that
people are searching for things related
to sustainability and that Google has
made a real commitment to sustainability
too you can learn more about
sustainability and Google's efforts at
sustainability.google so thanks to
Google for sponsoring that part of my
video and now back to magnets
what's happening is that as the middle
plate is falling through the field the
number of magnetic field lines passing
through it is changing this change in
magnetic flux induces electric currents
called Eddy currents in the plate which
create their own magnetic field that
opposes the change in flux this is known
as lenses law so if the plate is Falling
Towards a north magnetic pole the
induced currents create a north magnetic
pole themselves so that the plate is
repelled and so it falls much slower
so as that big Plate Falls there are
Eddy currents generated
in the middle
which should dissipate some energy as
heat so I want to see if we can see that
it's actually slowing down now
because it's in a much higher field now
it is slight but I think you can see
that the plate is warming up a bit as it
falls
previously I visited an electromagnetic
levitator at the palace of Discovery in
Paris
it uses an alternating current to
levitate a plate but the Eddy currents
in that plate generate so much heat that
water actually boils on its surface
check out how hot this plate is
I like to think of lenses law as the no
you don't law because whatever you try
to do nature acts to oppose you there
you go
if the plate is falling Eddy currents
are induced to slow its descent
but if you try to pick up the plate
nature also says no you don't
in this case a South magnetic pole is
induced under the plate attracting it
back to the magnet they don't know if
I'm weak or if this is actually insanely
all right
there you go oh my goodness you're
strong like bull no matter how hard I
tried to push the plate down it just
wouldn't go very fast because even if I
could speed it up a little bit that
would increase the rate of change of
flux and hence the induced currents and
their Associated magnetic field
that is ridiculous
yeah
we tried a number of other conductive
but non-ferromagnetic objects around the
magnet like this thick cylinder of
aluminum drop it straight on the magnet
and nature says no you don't try to roll
it across the top
no you don't he just refuses to roll
we wrapped up a volleyball in aluminum
foil and passed it across the magnet
or dropped it straight in
again the changing magnetic flux induces
Eddy currents that produce their own
magnetic field to oppose the original
change in flux
we wanted to see just how much
deceleration The Fringe field of the 45
Tesla magnet could achieve so we decided
to fire projectiles from a potato cannon
across the top you ready
[Music]
this is what the projectile looked like
with the magnetic field off
and this is what it looked like with the
magnetic field on
if we compare the two shots you can see
that as the projectile enters the
magnetic field the induced Eddy currents
rotate the projectile so it remains
oriented along the magnetic field lines
and this minimizes the change in flux
that's experienced by the projectile
now some of the projectiles contain
coils of wire that were connected to
LEDs so the LEDs are actually biased
opposite polarity so no matter which
direction the field is coming in one of
them will be lit and we're hoping that
as it crosses through field you'll see
the change in color of LED of the nose
gun and sure enough these projectiles
light up showing how the induced
currents are changing in the coil
you know in all these cases the induced
electric energy is dissipated either as
light or heat but what if you had a
material that didn't dissipate energy
like a superconductor below its critical
temperature
there are two important things to know
about the high temperature
superconductor we're using here first
below its critical temperature most of
the material has zero electrical
resistance which means if you bring a
magnet close to it currents will be
induced to oppose the change in flux and
since it's a superconductor those
currents can persist indefinitely and
expel all of the magnetic field
second there are some filaments through
the material that are not
superconducting there's defects that are
engineered into the superconductors a
second phase that traps those magnetic
field lines and keeps them from moving
it can no longer rise or fall because
it's kind of locked in that magnetic
configuration
this is the human levitator it consists
of a 90 pound or 40 kilogram magnet
hovering above a ring of superconductors
so it's I'm staying on the magnet and
underneath is the superconductor that's
right when I stand on the magnet it is
pressed down into the superconductors
but the increase in magnetic flux is
opposed by currents in the
superconductors creating a magnetic
field that repels the magnetic field
from the magnet I'm standing on I
maintain my angular momentum oh yeah
so I remain levitating above the
superconductors
[Music]
for real
it's up to you
[Music]
now there's another way to levitate in a
magnetic field that has nothing to do
with induced Eddy currents and it's all
because all materials actually have
magnetic properties they're just hard to
see unless a strong magnetic field is
present some materials are always
attracted to magnetic fields they
display what's called paramagnetism
oxygen is like this we have liquid
oxygen dripping off the bottom here
and it gets attracted to the magnet it
doesn't matter if it's a North or South
magnetic pole the presence of the
external field causes the magnetic field
of material to strengthen the overall
magnetic field and that causes
attraction
other materials in fact most materials
are repelled by a strong enough magnetic
field either north or south and this is
known as diamagnetism water is a good
example of this in the presence of the
external field the water molecules
become opposing magnets effectively and
so they are repelled
so here you can see how bringing a
magnet close to the surface of water
creates an indent
you can use this repulsion in a strong
enough magnetic field to levitate
objects you ordinarily wouldn't think of
as magnetic here we're using a slightly
weaker 31 Tesla magnet so that we can
use a periscope setup to actually see
into the bore and our camera
this strawberry will be magnetic in a
strong enough field well it's
diamagnetic right now it's just we're
not in a strong enough field right yeah
for us to see anything correct because
of the water water is diamagnetic and
there's a lot of water in strawberries
oh that's nice
oh that's beautiful
yeah it's beautiful
the same occurs with a raspberry or a
little piece of plastic Pizza
living organisms contain enough water
that they too can be levitated they
wouldn't do it here at the mag lab but
people have levitated frogs
[Music]
and grasshoppers
even mice and experiments meant to help
understand the effects of weightlessness
without having to go into space
so our very strong magnetic fields safe
for living things there are no lasting
effects there are no long-term effects
but we have noticed that there is the
possibility of actually polarizing the
stones that are in the inner ear and the
effect that that has on the rodent is
that the rodent actually spins
um so they go in circles they go in
circles it doesn't last for very long
it's only a few minutes after the animal
comes out of the magnet
so how do you actually make the world's
strongest magnet contrary to what I
expected you can't do it just with
superconducting magnets alone the
highest magnetic field you could
generate with superconducting wire was
nominally 20 Tesla that's because
superconductors have a limit to the
amount of magnetic field they can
withstand before they're no longer
superconducting so the solution is to
combine an outer superconducting
electromagnet with an inner
electromagnet made of ordinary wire so
the blue green and salmon colored bits
that's the superconducting outsert that
produces 11.5 Tesla inside of that we
put a resistive magnet that produces 33
and a half Tesla Maxwell's equations
Fields add we get 45 Tesla but making
high field magnets with ordinary
resistive wire is really hard for a wire
wound magnet like a junkyard magnet a
traditional electromagnet the highest
magnetic field you can get is about two
Tesla and the reason is that you cannot
get the heat out of the innermost
windings so back in the 1950s Francis
bitter up at MIT he realized that
physics doesn't care what shape the
conductor is you can take your round
wire and smash it into a very thin plate
if you then stack those plates with
alternating insulators
you make a helix that electrically looks
just like that
but now I can push cooling water axially
through the stack of conductor so that
means that innermost part I can now pull
all that heat away which means I can go
to much much much much much much higher
currents through these coils up to 57
000 amps then what you can do with a
traditional wire round electromagnet and
that gives you like 34 Tesla that that
gives you 33.5 but it's stacked up so we
stack all of these up in a stacking jig
they're lined up with tie rods we then
put about 20 tons of force on it and
then lock those tie rods down and that
holds the coil together and gives us our
electrical connection between each turn
and we're pushing you know several
thousand gallons per minute of deionized
water through those coils to keep them
cold because otherwise it melts and
you're done
occasionally you get material failure
that happens when the material goes past
its plastic limit and starts flexing
either into the coil next to it or maybe
even shorting to ground and this is what
happened here the coil plastically
failed meaning the metal went beyond its
springy characteristics where it would
come back and it's just completely
deformed which drove it into the coil
next to it
burn through the insulator
and then vaporized all of this metal you
can see more
on the inside it killed this coil which
is the v-coil
but because it failed on the inner Edge
it killed the a coil failed on the Outer
Edge it also killed the sea coil
so that was an expensive failure yeah
yeah
the record is the highest continuous
magnetic field in the world period China
recently commissioned their 45 Tesla
hybrid very similar in concept to ours
so now there's two of them in the world
running the strongest magnets on the
planet takes a lot of energy the mag lab
uses a significant fraction of
tallahassee's electricity so we can
consume with all four power supplies at
full blast about eight percent of their
total generating capacity with the
electricity budget of this place so
nominal 250 to 300 000 a month holy crap
yeah yeah that's a lot so we operate in
their federally mandated Reserve which
every utility has to have they have to
have that available to push into the
grid if there's a problem we have a deal
set up with the city so that they can
actually make money off that power that
they have to produce but which they
can't sell the flip side is when they
need it we ramp down and we can go down
much faster than they can spin up a
Jenny why do you need 45 pesos
there are a couple things that drive
material Discovery one of them is just
growing a new material the other one is
putting it in an extreme environment
like high magnetic fields High electric
Fields high pressure ultra low
temperature another axis is taking an
existing material and improving its
cleanliness so getting all the
impurities out so as you drop the
impurities in the material you're
reducing where the electrons scatter
from in there and that improves the
properties enables you to see things
that you're never able to see before
we've only just barely scratched the
surface on what can be done with this
people are going to look back about 25
years from now and this will be the
inflection point this five-year period
oh